We have a voicemail number two, one nine two
David P. this color has the idea of a citizen's
arrest on Donald Trump.
Let's take a listen.
Hi, I'm calling from Connecticut.
My name is Kelly.
Um, I have a very strange question and I'm,
I don't know if this is possible or not, but
I'd like to know, could I make a citizen's
arrest?
Could I have Donald Trump arrested for several
things that I can think of a whole bunch of
off the top of my head.
I would really like to know what the laws
are on that.
What, why can't we do something about the
blatant breaking of our laws?
It's the things that he exhibits on a daily
basis.
Just wondering, just throwing it out there.
I'd be willing to sign up for it.
I'd be willing to figure out a way to do it.
Yeah.
Listen, um, citizens arrest is something that
exists there.
There are situations where private individuals
have the power to make an arrest without a
warrant.
These are known as citizens arrests.
Typically they are when just normal people
will detain a criminal themselves or direct
police officers to detain a criminal or whatever
the case may be.
Um, I think that it is not a good use of time
thinking about how to citizens arrest Donald
Trump, whatever the legal questions are about
citizens arresting a president, you're not
going to be able to get close to the president.
What would secret service protection and everything
else that is going on?
Uh, we don't even know if the president can
be arrested in a normal way.
It's sort of a matter of a high level legal
discussions.
My suggestion is I would not think too much
about this.
I would think about other forms of activism.
I understand your frustrations.
I understand what you're saying.
You, if you tried this would likely end up
being charged for attacking the president
and you might actually end up in jail or prison.
I'm not saying that's the right thing, but
what I'm telling you is that is the most likely
outcome.
I wouldn't do it if I were you.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Donald Trump's proposed budget calls for increasing
military spending again and for cutting domestic
social programs.
Again, we will look at the details on the
bonus show.
There is also a war on architectural diversity
that is weaponizing Greek columns on buildings.
This is bonkers and we're going to talk about
it.
We will also talk about producers, Pat and
max canvassing for Bernie in New Hampshire
in advance of tomorrow's primary.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show,
get instant access by becoming a member@joinpacman.com
or a patron at patrion.com/david [inaudible],
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].